من الكويت ينضم الينا شاعر خالد البذال
صبحك الله بالخير عظم الله اجرك تعازينا
لك انت صديق للفنان عبد الكريم عبد القادر
وكذلك لاسرته عزائنا انه هو دائما موجود
معانا في ذكرياتنا في حياتنا اليوميه تفضل
خالد
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير اخوي عادل صبح على
اخواننا ومشاهدينا في الوطن العربي
طبعا
احنا
يعتصروا قلوبنا الحزن
والعنفقدان هذا العلم من اعلام الوطن
العربي الفنان الكبير عبد الكريم عبد
القادر طبعا
يمكن في مقدمتكم لخصتوا يعني شيء بسيط من
مسيرته الفنيه اللي راكبه 60 عام
وعاصرها خمس اجيال من من من الاجيال اللي
اللي عاشوا على ذكريات وعلى
مشاويرهم
والامهم وافراحهم
يعني عبد الكريم كان مصاحب الجميع في في
احساسه وفي شعوره صغار وكبار رحمه الله
على ابو خالد وانا سعيد يا حبيبي في
نعم نعم يا عادل طبعا انا انا اللي اتفضل
نظري بانه يعني رغم هذه المسيره الفنيه
العملاقه اللي امتدت لعقود من الزمن ورغم
وجوده بذاكره كل الكويتيين والخليجيين
ايضا بهذه الصوره الحرفيه الكبيره الكبيره
الا انه كان هو يوصف نفسه بانه هو محب
للفن وفنان غير محترف كمان يعني هذا اذا
يدل على شيء على تواضع
اكثر عن هذا الجانب من شخصيته استاذ خالد
اي نعم
شخصيته اختي الكريمه عبد الكريم عبد
القادر انا اكثر من مره قلتها هو شخصيته
اللي تسمعينها في الاغاني
والله العظيم اي شخصيته هذه انسان محب
انسان رومانسي انسان عاطفي عمري عمري ما
سمعت صوته ولا عمري شفت سمعته اعصب انا 27
سنه ملازمه في المكتب
الصبح من الساعه 9:00 نداوم الى الساعه
وحده الظهر ومن الساعه 4:00 العصر الى
الساعه ثمانيه عمري ما شفته عصب ولا زعل
ولا ولا طول صوته ولا شيء الا اذا في اذا
كان في شغل ولا كان في عمل نبي نحضر عمل
ولا ويا شعراء ولا ويا ملحنين يكون هناك
في عنده تحفظه
ويعني
انسان هذه هذه طبيعته اللي تسمعها بالشريط
واللي تسمعونها اغانيها هي هذه شخصيته ما
فيها تصنع ولا فيها تلون يعني خليني خليني
اسال بانه اليوم انا اعرف انه يعني في
حولي في هذا المكتب كنت دائما بعض لكن
خليني انا على المستوى الشخصي ايضا اعرف
عبد الكريم عبد القادر هذا الفنان كلمتين
يا حبيب عمري يا حبيب قلبي دائما
يكررها في حديثه معك هالدرجه كان رومانسي
بالفعل ولا انه والله هذه ينم على شيء من
داخله حتى في اختيار الكلمات يتدخل بتغيير
الكلمات خالد
[موسيقى]
طبعا عادل يعني انت مثل ما قلت يا حبيب
قلبي ويا حبيب عمري لانه انسان يعادل
انسان مخلوق من من
اسمها يعني انسان من نسمه ما في تصنع اكيد
بالنسبه لا انت تشتغل تشتغل وياه عبد
الكريم عبد القادر ترى عبد الكريم عبد
القادر تشتغل وياه مو اي واحد يقدر يشتغل
وياه عبد القادر انت اذا تبي تقدم نصك له
انت تتعب تتعب عبد الكريم
يعني الشاعر اللي ما يقدر يواصل ويا عبد
الكريم يتعب لانه
حريص حريص
وثانيا عادل لازم اذا خلص
واعتمد النص وهو يكتب بايده عشان اذا بروح
يركب صوتها وهو يكون كاتبه على خط ايده
اذا كتب كتب النص على خط ايده اعرف انه
اعتمده
وكذلك الالحان مو انت اللي تسمعها الالحان
هذا والصوت ترى ترى يمر في في مراحل كثيره
على ما يطلع للناس عنده
من نقطه بدايه حبيت لو هيك عندي شويه فضول
اعرف هل في اشياء احنا استاذ خالد ما
بنعرفها عن الفنان الراحل الكبير هيك لو
تعطينا معلومات يعني
العوامه
ما بيعرفوها وحبيت كمان اسالك عن كيف
استطاع انه يواكب تغير الذوق العام سواء
كان العربي او الخليجي او الكويتي فيما
يتعلق
الموسيقى والاغاني من زمن الزمن الكلاسيكي
الى الزمن المعاصر
[موسيقى]
يعني انا بقول لك شيء عنه يعني الله يذكره
بالخير امس المستشار تركي ال الشيخ قال كل
ما في في مداخله في تلفزيون الكويت قال
عبد الكريم عبد القادر عزيز نفس وفعلا
واللي قاله مع المستشار التركي هذا الناس
اللي ما تعرفه انه جميع العروض تجي وجميع
يعني المبالغ والماده تجيه هذا الشيء
المهم اللي لازم يعرفونه الناس انه يقدم
رساله مثل ما قلتي اختي مثل ما قال اخوي
عادل انه هو قال لكم انه هاوي مو محترف
للفن
يعني بالنسبه للموسيقى وهو يعني
رائد من رواد الفن العربي ورمز من رموز
الفن الكويتي يعني احنا في في رحيله راح
يكون هناك فراغ كبير
بالساحه
الكويتيه والساحر الخليجيه لانه لو تدري
وتدرون شنو
الوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي شنو صار فيها
لحد اليوم لحد الساعه هذه يعني شيء مهول
شيء ما يعني انا اول مره اشوف بحياتي يعني
شو نقول نقول احنا بالاخير يعني يعني
الواحد ما يطلب له المغفره
يعني احنا بشاعر خالد البذال شاكرين لك
فقط نؤكد بانه يعني المستشار تركي ال
الشيخ في تغريدته حتى قال بانه كان من
المفترض انه يعني تكريم فنان الفنان عبد
الكريم عبد القادر يكون في شهر اكتوبر او
حتى نوفمبر وكان بصدد الاتفاق مع ابن خالد
وترتيب هذه الامور لكن القدر كان اسرع في
كلمتي ولربما اكيد ستكون ليله مختلفه من
هذه الليالي التي يكرم فيها الفنان خالد
يعني راح يبقى معانا بذكرياتنا راح يبقى
معانا بكل
اغنيه تذكرنا بن عم بالابيض والاسود
بالالوان وحتى الان شكرا جزيلا للشاعر
خالد البدال من الكويت يعطيك الف عافيه
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات